hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well Rene Descartes
begins his meditations in the very first
one of them by bringing into doubt the
things of the senses things that we
perceive through the intermediary of
vision hearing or in other ways that are
in some way mediated through the senses
so he tells us that he has learned many
things in his life through all of these
senses or by the senses that would
include not just the things that he has
had direct sensory experience of like
you know for example seeing this book in
front of me or the track board that
you're looking at right now but also the
things that we received through the
intermediary of the senses like for
example people telling us about what
they themselves have seen in in some
respect that would be even less reliable
than the things which we witness ourself
but they Kurt knows from his own
experience that our senses sometimes do
deceive us and we can think of many
examples that were long
sort of tropes by his time for example
when you stick a stick into the water it
looks like it's bent but we know that
it's not actually bent or to use another
one when you see a square tower and a
great distance it actually looks like
perhaps it's round and there's all sorts
of other things along these lines that
we can bring up as examples as a matter
of fact although dick Hart didn't really
picture this to himself in his own time
understandably enough what you're
watching right now is really strictly
speaking an illusion it is you know a
recording of me talking to you here in
my home studio but by the time that
you're watching this or hearing my voice
whatever happened is long sense passed
it's sort of like a painting and he uses
examples of paintings and and other
similar imagery work in his discussion
of this this issue so he knows to recap
that there's many ways in which the
senses could be deceiving us and you
know as an example of that things at a
distance so he asks himself okay we can
doubt some of those matters maybe once I
get past a certain range I should
actually be a little bit
cherri of agreeing to what my senses say
I hear a sound far off is it a kitten is
it a human baby is it perhaps a
recording of something you know if I
take my glasses off my range of good
perception is drastically reduced but
what about the things that are so to
speak right up in our faces what about
the experiences that we're having right
now and Descartes says for example now
of course he's writing this after the
fact he says although the sense
sometimes do deceive us when they have
to do with
things that are hard to perceive and
greatly distant from us we can recognize
perhaps many other things that we can't
reasonably doubt because we we know them
through this medium of the senses for
example that I am here sitting in front
of the fire dressed in a robe Duchamp
you know sort of nighttime gear having a
piece of paper between my hands and
other things of that nature so can I
doubt right now that I'm right in front
of this chalkboard or that I'm wearing
it's hi or anything along those lines
and at first he says I'm not going to
consider the cases of the Insane
although he actually names laughs quite
a few different types of people who are
crazy says I'm not gonna isn't this
perhaps to compare myself to the crazy
people who have their brains so troubled
and obfuscated by the dark vapors of
bile that they assure other people
constantly that their kings or when
they're actually poor that they are
dressed in gold and purple when they're
actually naked or imagine themselves for
example to be made of glass which was
actually a problem at the time and some
people still have those beliefs and
Descartes says let's put that aside what
are talking about insanity here don't we
all go through something that should
allow us to call our sensual perceptions
into question
like for example dreaming don't we
believe all sorts of things to be true
that aren't actually the case you know
for example I've had many dreams he says
where I am sitting here in front of this
fire with a piece of paper in my
hands how do I know that right now I'm
not actually dreaming I mean the
perceptions that I have are pretty clear
and they certainly seem convincing but I
know that in the past when I have been
dreaming I have dreamed things that
fooled me into thinking that I was in my
waking life just to give you an example
from my own experience I've had dreams
where I actually punched in at work
worked an entire shift punched back out
and then woke up from the dream
realizing that now I had to go to work
again and that I didn't get paid for the
eight hours of labor that I put in eight
hours of imaginary labor that I had
simply dreamed how can we tell the
difference between dreaming and waking
life and this is an object that you know
subject rather is going to say it's an
object of many movies and novels because
it's so fascinating of a problem maybe
we could be in fact caught in a dream
how would we tell the difference and a
curt says that from where I sit right
now I don't actually see any marks or
criteria by which I can actually
determine whether I'm sleeping or
whether I'm awake whether the
perceptions that I'm having are true or
the perceptions that I'm having our
false at least in the sense that they
don't represent reality the reality
would be me in my bed in say pajamas or
something like that he says there are no
indices and marks certain enough that I
can distinguish cleanly or clearly knit
them all between sleeping and and
awakening and I'm surprised by this he
says and so that raises some some
problems he says well alright let's
concede that let's say
I can't actually tell the difference
between dreaming and waking at least
there has to be some truth in the
perceptions that I'm having you know he
says the components of these dreams
should be in fact real or true right
there has to be something in them so he
says for example all the things that I
that are represented in sleep are sort
of like paintings which have to be
formed by resemblance by similarity to
something real and true but then again
don't painters paint things that we know
don't exist well at least we're pretty
sure don't exist in real life like
mythological creatures and he says well
yes that's that's quite true you know he
says it's true that painters represents
sirens and satyrs and you know bizarre
and extraordinary forms but they can't
attribute to them forms and natures that
are entirely original entirely new why
because they're made of a certain Milosh
a certain mixture and composition of the
members of different animals so you know
we picture a unicorn for example and
there are no unicorns in real life but
we imagine this usually white horse
right and then we just put a horn on its
head
we're using our productive capacity of
imagination to create that and we can do
that because we've seen horns and we've
seen horses so at least there have to be
horns and horses then right he says well
you know we could be wrong about that
but maybe there's more simple things he
says he says for the same reason you
know these these general thing
maybe they could be imaginary but we do
have to at least admit that there are
things that are simpler and more
universal
that would be true and existence and we
would put those together perhaps into
certain arrangements and that would give
us the the information the ideas that we
have streaming into us we think from the
census so he says the mixture of which
no more nor less than that of certain
true colors all these images of things
that reside in our thought whether
they're real and true or or you know
imaginary and fantastic would be formed
so what would this include he says well
this would include corporeal nature in
general and its extension and as well as
that the figure or shape or structure of
these extended things their quantity or
greatness and their number at least
those things you would think would be
something we can rely upon and now we've
actually gone quite far away from the
the world that we we know and we're
perceiving or at least think we're
perceiving right
and now we're getting to a lower level
structure and he said well you know even
in a dream all of these things would
still be reliable even if we can't tell
that we're in a dream we'll see whether
the heart can actually rest everything
on that foundation or not
you